[Music]  come on Brad  I saw Freya in an article and papers  calling it britain's loneliest dog she  has lived in a shelter her entire life  six years no one wanted her 18,000  people actually saw her didn't take her  I was looking for a dog and some decided  to take her on by which time Michael Bay  had shown interest in her action and I  said first of all we give her part  transformers know she is working with  Sir Anthony Hopkins her very first woman  she's done a great job good good good  good  such a good actor so we never dreamt  about having such a role in the film it  is a great animal lover and that said my  house off to him for giving her this  chance so rat day how's the dog good  yes great phrase diet remain amazing  this right here oh look go this way  right  yeah baby  I've rescued so many and they do love  you more  man's best friends  this is the first time we are we're  getting ready to do a big sequence  there's an explosion